Remember the video about pseudo-classical classing, where I pointed out
that there were two different categories of code going on in the Car class.
This is the exact moment where that distinction becomes extremely interesting.
So far, we've made it so that the differentiation code in
the subclass will call out the differentiation code available in the superclass.
But due to the fact we're using prototype chains to implement an inheritance,
we also need to wire up the subclass prototype to the superclass prototype,
to allow the similarity code to be inherited as well.
Amy does delegate Van.prototype, but
neither amy nor Van.prototype have any relationship with Car.prototype yet.
In order to set up that relationship, we want to make it so
that Van.prototype delegates to Car.prototype.
This is how we are going to make the shared methods available from Car onto Van.
If we succeed, then a lookup to amy.move will fall through the amy object,
and up to the van prototype, which will fail.
And finally, fall all the way through to the Car prototype.
Ideally, we would be able to update Van.prototype such that it
would delegate it's field lookups to Car.prototype.
In memory, we would expect it to work rather like this.
The Van.prototype object should be made to delegate all the way up to
the Car.prototype object.
In this way, it would be very similar to car instances,
because both would delegate field lookups to the Car prototype property.
But this actually isn't allowed in the official version of the language.
Instead, we're going to have to overwrite the originally provided prototype
object with the brand new object that we create.
So what object exactly do we want to be assigning in place of
the old Van.prototype object?
It might surprise you that pseudo-classical subclasses will work just fine
after a reassignment like this.
And that's because the instance delegation is set up
only when the constructor actually runs.
This prototype replacement happens right alongside the constructor definition
and so that's plenty of time before we actually instantiate any objects.
People often propose that Van.prototype could simply be made to
equal Car.prototype.
But remember, JavaScript doesn't do any copying when you assign one variable or
property to be equal to another one.
If that was the case, then it would be impossible to add any methods to
the Car prototype that weren't also on the Van prototype and vice versa.
So adding a Van.prototype.grab would have the effect of
modifying Car.prototype to also have a .grab method.
In short, we definitely don't want our Van.prototype to be
the exact same object in memory as the Car.prototype object.
So instead of making Van.prototype equal the same exact object as Car.prototype,
how can we make sure that the Van prototype will delegate its
field lookups to Car.prototype?
Fill in the code for yourself.